though I grab a seat man thank you so
much dude it's so good to have you
around I just love spending time with
you Anthony did you enjoy the eviction
I love the eviction best experience of
my life you know by far very stressful
extremely stressful but yeah it was it
was fantastic
you know Samuel was a different person
in the eviction in the board room was
very challenging
I told him a quick funny story about the
eviction so I haven't have an Apple
watch and it tells me on my heartrate so
my resting heart rates like 79 after the
first boardroom you've watched the first
episode right we didn't do particularly
well after the first boardroom I come
out and I look at my watch and it says
Apple watch detected that your heart
rate went above 120 BPM while you appear
to be inactive it's fine stress free
keynotes I need to go see a doctor it's
like you need to lie down you know well
you did really well in the episode I
think we'd all agree after watching
episode one two and three that you're
definitely looking like you could be
even be a potential one of the winners
or in the finals would you guys are
great
so really doing well talk to me about I
mean I know you don't
you've done all of these strategies very
successfully he's made tens of thousands
of pounds deal sourcing he's financially
free alone from these rent to essays
he's got HMOs he's raised finance he did
joint ventures but you're probably most
lucrative and exciting strategy is when
you buy houses refurbish them with none
of your own money refinance them and
then rent them and make a passive income
with infinite returns like that's you're
the king at that and I'm just so it's
it's I think you know sometimes people
say to me Samuel how many properties do
you own you know how what's your net
worth and stuff and I'm like you know
what I don't even care don't even matter
I I don't even care about my net worth I
don't care about how many houses I don't
care about my castle I don't care about
my I don't care but the thing I care
about is how successful my students are
and I'm so proud of you Anthony thank
you
it's so proud here so so tell us man
telestroke torture me about taught me
through simply what the strategy is and
and how you've made it work so
brilliantly so like samuel said this is
the best strategy in my opinion and i'm
going to change the world with this
strategy because i'm going to take all
these houses that need work I'm going to
refurbish them refinance them I'm gonna
put tenants in them but I'm also gonna
end up with a free house in most of the
instances so I've bought three houses
like this so far and like Samuel said
I've used absolutely none of my own
money to buy them and now I'm you know
buy refurbish refinance is a bit like
development but on a smaller scale so
you'll find a property buy it below
market value it will generally require a
refurbishment to it so your
refurbishment refurbish the property
with an exit strategy to then refinance
the property at a higher value which
means you can pull all or most of your
money back out and because this strategy
is like some of that's so lucrative the
this is a great strategy to find
investors for so the first house I found
I raised twenty four thousand pound to
buy the house using an investor's money
I bought it on a mortgage and and we
refinance it in nine months time so
getting refinance in two months time
we're gonna leave some of the investors
money in there but he's getting the
return on his money so and I'm gonna go
with a house from this I'm gonna get
like so I'm gonna said an infinite
return on this house because I'm gonna
I'm gonna be generating every single
month from this property by putting no
money into it whatsoever so it is a
fantastic strategy so how do you
identify these these diamond properties
like where do you find them the thing is
it's all down to the training and I mean
this training is level one when you go
on to the Academy you'll meet Trevor cut
more who who really is the master at
this so you'll find the properties in
the exact same way but all these rundown
properties that you see most people just
skim over them and think ah that's too
much work I won't be able to qualify the
refurbishment on things like that but
what I'll do is I'll look at the
properties I'll use the calculator that
I've put together with people like
Trevor from the Academy and then
obviously some of my builders and I can
literally put in how many windows I need
six how much should I need the kitchen I
need this I need this it'll spit me a
figure out you need
x-amount a thousand pounds refurb and
then I know I'll go and view this
property now so the same principle of
ringing the agent and saying would you
accept an offer of this I do it in
Reverse but work out does the refurbish
reefer work on the property then I'll go
and view it and I'll qualify my refurb
and put the offer it based on what I
think the N value is going to be so
using things like Maus price right move
to qualify what the area is like and and
you know generally I'll come out with a
really good figure to be out of work you
know on the because on the Academy we
have a program called recycle recycle
your cash and I know on the recycle your
cash program we specifically weekly
following properties just like that
exactly that need work and basically I'm
such a flipchart guy I just have to just
do some it real quick because this is
this is the essence of the program and
its really simple would you like to
learn a quick new thing about this
strategy guys hello alright so these are
the figures you need and this is what
Anthony's mastered so well so there's
only three figures that you need to know
the first figure is what's the purchase
price what's the purchase price how much
can you buy this rundown
oby property for what's the lowest that
they'll accept what's the line that you
use in Hanson hey when you're trying to
get a good deal and you want to know
what the bottom what their bottom line
is and so sorry said that again what
what what's the closing line when you're
talking to a vendor what do you say to
get their bottom line so usually I will
ask them what's the lowest they can
accept and still live yeah they'll give
me the bottom I figure than at this
let's do it let's do let's do it so so
so Antony what's the bottom if I was to
buy is cash tomorrow what's the bottom
the lowest that you could accept but
still live with that's how it is along
silence is that am i right yeah
sometimes as long as a minute and you'll
see this on my American video with the
financial returns I'll say and they're
never just and they're going and I'm
just silent have you seen this yeah and
under silent the person that speaks
first is the person that loses I'm
alright and tonight exactly so Energy's
mastered this so that's the first thing
what's the purchase price then the
thing is how much is the refurb gonna
cost and Anthony's he's talked about
we've given we give our Academy members
a really cool sheet where you can work
out how much things are going to cost so
once you know the purchase price and the
refurb cost you don't need to know what
is the done up value those are the only
three figures you need to know that's it
when you know those three figures you
can work out how if it's going to be
lucrative or not if the purchase price
plus the refurb is a hundred grand but
the done up value is only one hundred
and five grand so good
if this is a hundred grand but the done
of value is one hundred and fifty grand
nice so that's the figures that we work
on right exactly then you can either
sell the property or you can get a new
mortgage on it and you can refinance it
back up to its true value and by the way
you know the whole you know when they
when they brought in the six month rule
we have to wait six months to refinance
the scrapped it so now you so now you
can buy a house you can refurb it and
then you can refine upset straight away
so I know
maybe it speaks you a lender someone I
don't know maybe it could rhyme with
pent pill lions Canterlot they'll lend
you money you can add value as long as
you add value we find it oh yeah that's
how we're doing this man yeah so the one
I'm buying at the minute I'm gonna
refinance in less than three months I
bought it at sixty thousand pound and
like Samuel said I've worked out the
refurb and this house is fantastic
because I'm gonna use a bridging loan to
buy this property as well as an
investor's money I'm really excited
about bridging loans okay they're
bridging loan is sometimes a pain
because it's like oh it's like you've
got to go through the hoops to fill out
the forms and all that so because my
students like Anthony because Anthony
keeps having to get bridging loans all
the time it's a pain oh how could
declined and see what what am i doing so
like something said him and I had a
business called the other day Simon was
gonna set a bridging company up for
lease Academy members so he's gonna
completely break down the barriers for
bridging I've already set one up I just
had my first I just had my first and I
can't remember
I just letting them half a million
unfamiliar and it was it was it was done
within like 20 24 hours it's just like I
want half a million to do this deal it's
have a look maybe 24 hours accepted next
day boom half a million litres account
if you pay depends on the deal the deal
but the reason I've done it it's because
I'm sick and tired of my caddy members
being declined me everything for me is
mission I'll make money sometimes that's
fun mission says freakin exciting times
so come on carry on them to me what's
going on so like I said the one I'm
buying at the minute I'm using the
bridging loan to buy it so with a
bridging loan typically you can leverage
about sixty five percent of the property
thirty five percent will be the fees for
bridging because they obviously it's
worked on retained interest basis so
they'll work out the interest on the
bridging loan when you tell them how
many months you're gonna have it for and
that's deducted from how much they'll
give you on the bridge so let's look at
this so let's say you give me
give me a case today gives me the last
case today so the one I'm working at
purchase price is 60,000 pounds
all right so 60 grand do you need
personally to put that 60 grand down no
come from so sorry well this one and
investors putting it down so you get 60
grand from an investor why would he give
you 60 grand
well investors actually give me the
deposit for the bridge so I'm getting
our bridging loan okay and investors
giving me the deposit for those yeah so
he's given me 23 thousand pound which
covers my fees and covers the deposit
for the bridge in and then the rest to
get in a bridging and the fantastic with
this one on the bridging loan is I'm
getting a hundred percent refurbishment
paid on the bridging loan so you're not
putting up any of your own money down
not a penny and then how much will the
refurb cost it's a refurbishment on this
one's nine thousand pounds she's been
through the buy refurbishments
masterclass so purchase price sixty
refurb nine thousand so all in sixty
nine thousand plus fees don't up value
on the property ninety five thousand
pounds at the end of the deal it'll
leave three thousand pounds in the deal
how many of you will be okay with buying
a house with three thousand pounds of
course and how much you gonna make so on
this one I'll make about two hundred and
fifty pounds a month profit but over the
year this is a one hundred and six
percent return on the investment so
after a year I'm gonna end up with a
free house I'm gonna make capital
appreciation on because the area I'm
buying it in they've got hate just two
coming along so I know like samuel said
I've bought in an area that's bottom
doubt so in three years time five years
time I know this house is going to go up
substantially in value what's the big
burn for you but I why are you doing
this the big plan for me is I've lived
in a crappy house I've been there you
know honestly I lived in this house at
single-pane windows it had mold on the
wall the landlord didn't care about me
at all and it was tough because you got
have a hard day at work like somebody
said I was in retail 60 hours a week and
you come home and that's where you get
your rest bite and when your house is
crap you don't get that rest buy and so
I'm sick and tired of all these crappy
landlords and I'm just going to corner
the market I'm gonna refurbishment all
these properties that
there's 600,000 properties in the UK
that are empty you know and we'll find
these properties that everywhere you
know refurbishment them revalue them let
them out to tenants you know you see
them on Rightmove now some fantastic
properties and that's what investors are
doing and all these ones with the
Magnolia walls in the crap are just
going to disappear and that's why
section 24 worries all of these
landlords because they haven't got a
clue what they're doing so good and the
crazy thing is how what what did you
know about property when you when you
first met me oh I was talking to a few
of you earlier and the the ROI
calculator I could not get that for the
life of me could not oh yeah yeah I
could not get it for the life of me it
took me it took me about two weeks after
the crash course and my brother's to sit
down and really explain it to me but
wouldn't you get it you get it and then
you know obviously when I signed it to
the Academy and it you know like I say
so yeah November assignments Academy oh
but you start your training in jail all
right so we saw underpin November he
started his first training in January
February March April May for frigging
months of training and this is the man
is become I now control eleven
properties probably right that's the
thing that's why I say you can go to you
can spend forty thousand pounds learning
about I don't know what you learn about
chemistry or drama or you can join the
Academy and learn to become financially
free change your life in change other
people like that's it the thing is with
this strategy once you learn the
foundations of it you can go on to
bigger projects we viewed a property
last week so it's a church and we're
gonna convert it into 14 apartments
three hundred thousand pound purchase
price three take you to other churches
oh no no no this is a derelict one yeah
three hundred thousand pound purchase
price three hundred thousand pound
refurb you know once we we get this
development value it's gonna be worth
1.3 million we're gonna pull 300
thousand pound out of the property it's
the same as what I told you about I told
you about the piece of land I've just
bought a piece of land I bought a piece
of land I bought the land for three
hundred and thirty thousand pounds I'm
then going to build six houses on it
that's going to cost me about
half a million just shy of half a
million talking about 800-thousand all
in i've already had a rick's value us
give me an end value of 1.3 million so
at the end I'll just sell off the houses
and catch it like this this strategy by
refurbished refinance rent or by
refurbished cell is just incredible
give me some top pearls of advice
brother so the most important thing
about this strategy is all about you
refinance value because this strategy
hinges on you getting that right so I
always underestimate mine so if the
market is saying 95,000 pound I'll
underestimate it because then if my
refurbishment comes in low I've worked
out a worst case scenario and I'm gonna
end up still getting what I need so one
of the things that our teachers part of
you know the Academy is how to you know
best case worst case like the case so
every time I look at now I work out that
so best case is I get all my money out
worst case is I'm gonna leave
8 grand in their can I live with that
likely cases I'm gonna get X so that
that's the you know always with could
you use that same logic to whether you
should join the Academy remember yeah I
remember him having little best case
I've become financially free become
really successful blob-like great rank
up on worst case I end up like 15 grand
down waste learner time looks stupid now
I've got this debt that I need to pay
off
likely case I'll make my money back make
some friends buy a couple of houses and
for you it's worked our best case
exactly it's always been best case
because if you put the effort and you
will always get best case yeah I think
we've best case worst case not it case
just say is the worst case get equipped
with you forever if they're worse if the
best case is I'll make 5 grand but the
worst case is I end up crippled and
divorced don't do it but if the best
cases I'll become financially free and
the worst case is are just they it's a
small it's a small thing the MSP love
the question talk to me about some of
the cool surprises because you is it
true when I say you make a move I make a
move is that true yes so when samuel
says he if you make one move he'll make
10 that it rings true every single time
whenever i've made a move samuel rang me
said go down to London to meet Robert
Kiyosaki do you do you want to come and
come
mium so we went for dinner recently with
robert kiyosaki and he says well there's
also a course he's doing the course
two days after as well would you like to
go to that so he paid you know for us to
go to the course as well me and some of
the other caddy members and that was a
huge treat and we have Academy Awards so
you know just to be recognized there's
an award-winning property investor it's
huge
and we've even got some of the Academy
members in the room that Warren Awards
at this event and that's great to be
recognized like that you know and then
obviously the eviction as well wow what
an experience to be invited to because
I've taken action as part of the being
on the Academy so all these things come
by taking action and you know and I
can't thank Samuel enough because he
doesn't realize how much he's given me
and how much he's changed my life but
you know it's gonna help me forever and
I've made so many friends on the Academy
you know twelve months ago I almost lost
my job you know I lost my partner so you
know didn't have almost lost my house
and now I've got friends I've got a
family you know and I'll find actually
free and I couldn't be happier and it is
just by trusting myself and trust in the
training and taking that leap that
everything has come from this and today
again you still enjoy thank you yeah I'm
gonna be around all night behind man
you're in the hands all right wasn't I
thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
you